en direct la dernière jean marie qui
m'ont un peu d'eau et jean-marie jour
être remerciés d'être avec nous à chaque
fois sur la bourse michel boujenah et
avec michel boujenah la barre à partir
du 15 octobre au théâtre des variétés et
yako et qui étaient avec nous aussi qui
seront folies bergère le cas sur payé le
15 décembre puisque dix bons son
spectacle 100% libre et bien sûr et les
sur nrj de 15h à 20h cauet ouais c'est
assez commun ou d'un sursis c'est le
problème il y partage sur nrj il ya tous
les tous les ans il a une heure de plus
qu à nous faire pour lui voilà bonjour
marie est de la lgv moi j'aurais dit
cool avec moi dans tpm plus simplement
sas en corse
je veux le faire beaucoup d'amis ça va
j'ai pas de maison là-bas et la fille à
rentrer vient voir son père lui dit papa
je suis enceinte
le corse les rouges qui m'en prends le
fusil chargé la chaîne odyssée qui s'est
accumulé que je n'ai été prises et les
parties génitales d'un bac elle me doit
il vient il arrive là 14h et vient pour
te parler calmement et 2,6 du mec sont
là deux gros qu'athènes noir carré au
milieu les mots zine ya un mec qui
descend la cinquantaine c'est que ça il
ce proche du père de la fille du golan
je suis venu vous voir parce que en fait
c'est vrai j'ai c'est moi qui ai mis
votre fille enceinte mais je suis venu
vous voir pour vous dire que je lui
léguait dès aujourd'hui hui salon de
coiffure sur la côte d'azur est pour
vous deux concessions mercedes unis
c'est une
à marseille et je vous fais dès
maintenant un chèque de 5 millions
d'euros
oui que vous voudrez bien mettre sur le
compte de l'enfant à venir pour l'aider
à démarrer correctement dans la vie et
il ajouta rebonds et les canons se
baissent un petit peu elle ajouté et 10
et si par malheur autres filles perdent
l enfant le bervet tu la rebelle
[Applaudissements]